LGBTQ du Qatar.
blblblblblblblblblblblblblblblb.
- L'Angleterre préparait
son geste politique depuis
des matchs, d'un brassard
multicolcococontre
la discrimination en appui
à la communauté LGBT
Six autres sélections, dont
e e e allemande, devaient
emboîter le pas, mais
les menaces de la FIFA d'imposes
jaunes pour les joueurs les onte
anglais porte le brassard noir
approuvé par la FIFA sur
"pas de discrimination".
La sélection da l l l l l l l ;
un maillot unique pour dénoncer
l'exploitation des travailleurs
migrants qui ont construit
les stadesfrfrfrfrfrfrfrfrfrfrf.
La FIFA interdit au Danemark
de porter ces maillots lors
de ses parties.
La Fédération danoise s'est
entretenue avec les aiaiaiaiaiar
la situation des droits de
la personne.
Pas de anananananananananananat
Trudeau dit avoir de bonnes
relations avec le Qatar.
Il mise sur le dialogue.
les autorités qataries
est prévue cette semaine.
20 000 chandelles dans un stade
vide en Allemagne lors du
d'envoi de la Coupe du monde.
Geste d'éclat pour dénoncer les.
La pression internationale
sur le Qatar continue aussi
à l'étranger.
"Tout le mal causé par ce e e e.
C'est honteux",
affirme l'organisateur.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,-C-C-C-C-.